Denzel Washington Glory I want to thank
the academy I'm going to thank Ed zwick
Freddy Fields who did a fantastic job
who made what I consider to be at least
one of the best five films of the
year I'd like to thank my friend and
manager Flo
Allen fabulous Ed lamato and Todd Smith
and George
Freeman and God bless you my mother I
love you
my beautiful wife petta the kids my son
said he was going to make one of these
out of clay for me now I got the model
for
them uh I want to thank my first agent
the late Ruth arenson who who believed
in me uh I'd also like to to to pay
homage to the the 54th the black
soldiers who helped to make this country
free I thank God I thank you